we have a mental health crisis in this
country that there are record levels of
depression anxiety even suicide and
self-harm and one of the huge learnings
from your book was that there was a
surge in depression and anxiety among
young people that hand-in-hand with
widespread smartphone adoption and the
use of social media
there really is a mental health crisis
and I don't think that's an
overstatement at all for adolescents for
young adults we see these really
striking increases in depression in
anxiety in unhappiness loneliness and
those have been either unchanged or
actually improving for a while then
about 2011 or 2012 they start to rise in
these very very steep patterns and it's
not just survey data it's not just
people saying you know I you know I'm
not happy you know I feel useless or or
like I don't enjoy life they're saying
that it also shows up in behavior so
it's not just about self reports
emergency room admissions for self-harm
behaviors have skyrocketed same thing ER
visits for thinking about suicide or
attempting suicide for teenagers have
gone way up and most tragic of all the
actual suicide rate has doubled or even
tripled for young people since 2010 so
you look at all of that data it's so
consistent the the changes are so large
the next question you have to try to
answer is why what happened that might
explain you know why this is going on
and when I first started to see these
trends I had absolutely no idea what the
cost could be it was a real mystery it
was actually misaligned with economic
trends because that period from 2011 to
that the latest data we have is 2018
that was a period of economic expansion
thinks we're doing things were going
fairly
well in in the economy at least in terms
of unemployment and so on
so it actually was misaligned with that
and it was hard to think of any other
event that happened around that time and
kept going in the same direction
especially something that had a big
effect on people's lives but then one
day I stumbled across a poll from the
Pew Center for Research that showed the
end of 2012 was the first time that the
majority of Americans own smartphones
and that's when I started to realize
maybe that might have something to do
with it